this week's 48 hours investigates the
unsolved murders of four teenage girls
more than three decades ago in 1991
eliza thomas sarah and jennifer
harbison and amy ayers were shot and
killed in an austin texas yogurt shop
since then there have been several
confessions and even convictions
but all were overturned 48 hours
correspondent erin moriarty shows us how
modern dna testing could finally lead to
answers
so what is all of this here
these are my notes
it's been 30 years since jon jones led
the search for the killers of four
teenage girls in an austin yogurt shop
he has since retired from the austin
police department but the images of
december 6 1991 remain all too vivid i
can still see him eliza thomas jennifer
and sarah harbison and amy ayers have
been tied up and shot in the head
then the yogurt shop was set on fire a
task force worked to find suspects
we looked at everybody from family
members to drifters
meanwhile the victims families and the
city of austin grieved i remember the
shock
sonora thomas was 13 years old when her
only sibling eliza was murdered you just
hold on to anything you can to get
through these moments that are so
impossible
over the decades there were arrests even
convictions but those convictions were
overturned it left jones and the
families in emotional turmoil there is a
kind of torture that continues by the
fact that it's unsolved and it's ongoing
but there may be hope male dna called
ystr was found on one of the victims it
was an incomplete sample but with
advances in dna research there's a
chance that the sample obtained 30 years
ago
may solve this case
jones made a pledge to the families
involving the shirt he wore on the night
of the murders the next time they saw me
with that green and white shirt on that
that was a signal to them that you know
we knew who did it and jon jones has
kept that shirt all these years later i
just hope one of these days we can put
this thing to bed
for the family's sake
aaron moriarty joins us now she's
followed this case for decades and aaron
you were just saying this is the most
vicious case you've ever covered oh
absolutely there were four young women
who were in a yogurt shop you know with
a part-time job who would ever expect
sign and it wasn't just you know that
they were murdered they were shot then
they were piled on top of each other and
they were burned i mean there's nothing
worse and so you know what this case
made me realize that gail and i were
talking about this and i had not thought
about this is the impact on the
investigators we know these families
have lost their loved ones and and they
have to live with that but you don't
think the investigator also and jon
jones there was so much pressure to
solve this murder and he was diagnosed
with ptsd at one point his marriage fell
apart because he was so
single-minded he so much wanted to solve
this he's still holding on to the shirt
that he was wearing well because he
because there have been times when
people have been arrested and convicted
and he always promised the family i will
wear that shirt when i really believe
we've got the killers and he has not put
that shirt on yet what do we know about
that partial dna evidence that you just
mentioned okay this is hopeful so um you
know we hear about genetic genealogy
unfortunately what they have is just
partial so they can't actually put it
into a database yet but there were
recent tests originally the profile had
just 16 markers recent tests were able
to yield 25 markers so there's a hope
that the next set of tests will be able
to do more and maybe lead to the suspect
because i think most people believe
where that dna was
means that that person was involved and
it's going to lead to somebody outside
of the dna is there any other evidence
oh there is this strange clue that has
been just bugging me so much so the
people who are in the yogurt shop
remember two men in their 20s who were
not eating or drinking anything they
seem suspicious to the men they've never
been identified and all the years i've
done stories nobody's ever come forward
and said you know oh i those two guys
may have been and they have no pictures
of them no drawings it's just the phrase
yogurt chop and murders we were saying
those two words just don't go together
and that's right and they shouldn't kids
go it's quite funny
those two words shouldn't go together um
aaron moriarty thank you so much and you
can see aaron's report the yogurt shop
murders tomorrow night at 10 9 central
right here on cbs in the viacom cbs
streaming service paramount plus